los periodistas vuelven a verse
atrapados en la espiral de violencia de
las pandillas de haití esta vez se trata
de la bulldog y cerca de la capital
puerto príncipe una zona en la que las
bandas armadas se disputan el control lo
que ha producido intensos combates dos
periodistas jhon william a divulguen
wizo fueron encontrados muertos el
viernes un tercer periodista recibió
ayuda de los ciudadanos para escapar
uno que es un poco delgado recibió un
disparo en la sien la mano y en el
cuello hay otra herida de bala también
detrás de la cabeza en el lado derecho
[Música]
radio fm empleador de amadi dijo que él
estaba informado sobre cuestiones de
seguridad en la zona plagada de
violencia sólo para ser víctima de ella
y calificó el ataque como una barbaridad
en los últimos años se ha producido un
aumento de asesinatos de periodistas en
haití pero el decadente sistema judicial
del país ha sido incapaz de juzgar a
alguien de los asesinatos y esto del
asesinato de periodistas en haití es
solo un ejemplo más de la impunidad con
la que fueron asesinados por el mero
hecho de intentar decir la verdad el
asesinato del presidente joven el mois
el 7 de julio del año pasado ha dejado
un vacío de poder que ha permitido el
florecimiento de las bandas agravando
una crisis humanitaria en el empobrecido
país el gobierno ha prometido tomar
medidas contra las bandas a las que
culpa el aumento de los secuestros pero
las fuerzas policiales de haití están
muy mal equipadas y no han organizado
ninguna operación a gran escala contra
las bandas en casi un año